In the final question, I'd like to explore something.
I don't have a good answer for this, but I'd like you to play with those parameters over here--
the data weight, the weight smoother, the control parameters p_gain and d_gain.
Play with them, try to find a setting that gives me fewer collisions on average
than my current parameters and maybe reaches the goal even faster.
I should warn you these are about the best variables I could find,
but I didn't really apply twiddle to this.
I did more of an approximate investigation of what a good parameter might be.
When you apply twiddle and try this, you will find that it's hard to apply
because your function might never return, so you have to build in the time somehow.
It's fun playing with those to see if you can find a better solution than what I gave you.
If you do so, don't expect the correct answer from me. I didn't implement it myself.
But I want to give you the opportunity to play with those parameters
and see what the effects are on this solution.